hi I'm Erik Bosse and the vengers end
game ended in tears and tears in the
fabric of space-time as Captain America
embarked on one final mysterious mission
back in time that left us with so many
questions about the timeline of the
Marvel sinaitic universe like did Kat
make Jane Foster drink angry reality
stone sludge did cap spend decades slow
dancing with Peggy Carter while his best
friend was tortured and brainwashed in
Siberia and if time travel isn't
supposed to cause changes to your own
timeline why did cap age in the clint
eastwood like tony stark says an
avengers endgame when he messed with
time and it messes back with you and
makes you never want to meet your heroes
again but after i watched in games
several times i think i actually figured
out what happens then that offscreen
mission how it changes the MCU timeline
and how it actually sets up the future
of Marvel in a pretty cool way and still
make you like Captain America even more
spoiler warning if you haven't seen an
endgame yet though I guess I've already
said a lot about it Hey Joe Russo said
it's okay to talk about it okay so about
halfway through the film the ancient one
tells banner that the Avengers can steal
each of the Infinity stones in their
time heist but they must return them
because removing any of them permanently
would lead to too many chaotic branches
to break off from the main timeline both
the ancient one and banner were correct
in their descriptions of time travel
major changes to the Past like stealing
Infinity stones cause alternate
timelines to split off with that changed
branch timeline spiraling off into chaos
and your original timeline to remain
unchanged so after using the stones to
beat Thanos in the future cap goes alone
on one final trip to put them all back
he also takes Thor's previous hammer
Mjolnir since Thor stole that from the
2013 dark world timeline and along with
the stones the hammer needs to go back
to restore that timeline back to its
original order but here's where things
get a little confusing and the game does
not show us what cap did on this final
mission this time gift return instead he
just shows up sitting at the lake as an
old man revealing that he stayed in the
1940s living a beautiful life and now I
guess he's like feeding ducks this
appears to break the movie's own rules
about time travel like think about it if
cap went back to the 1940s and made the
major change of himself remaining in the
past that should have caused a new
branch timeline to form separate from
the main timeline with banner Bucky and
Sam at first it looks like they were
saying Steve rod
aged for decades and decades within this
timeline all while his original self
went into the ice came back out in 2011
and fought alongside the Avengers -
Captain America's the one we knew and a
secret creepy older one hiding in the
shadows saluting America's ass it also
presents all kind of weird ramifications
like if Bucky is still standing there at
the end of endgame with this Winter
Soldier armed in the present day that
would mean Captain America spent decades
with Peggy knowing that his best friend
was being tortured in Siberia
brainwashed by Hydra sure it didn't save
you friend also I'm giving my shield but
this fella I just met a few years ago
also not to get too dark about this but
hey you brought time travel into the
story we're gonna do this cap would have
woken up every morning knowing Hydra was
infiltrating and corrupting the US
government destabilizing the world
through terrorism and war like I get it
cap get in those two steps with Peggy
but you know you probably could have
stopped 9/11 but here is the deal the
directors confirmed that while there
were two caps in existence throughout
the 20th century one frozen and ice and
avenging with Avengers 1 Dancing with
Peggy the cap and Peggy that we see at
the end of the movie were in a new
separate timeline an off-screen history
when cap went back to Peggy he did
create a new branch timeline the
director said that this cap as an old
man somehow traveled from that branch
timeline back to this one to give Sam
his shield now I know I don't think Pym
particles allow you to hop laterally
among timelines I assume you have to go
back to the branch point and then go
back down that fork in the road but
notice how it is strange that cap looks
so old here like his Super Soldier Serum
was supposed to slow down his aging like
it did for Bucky another super soldier
who lived around 100 years but still
rocks dead mid to late 30s jealous
jawline this old man cat might have
lived several hundred years into a
future when quantum realm technology is
refined and multiverse travel is
possible without having to go back in
time to branch points and again we don't
know what happened in caps alternate
branch history that alternate cap could
have rescued Bucky from Siberia the two
of them could have kicked ass throughout
20th century world history preventing
9/11 lift away
maybe at some point in this alternate
history Steve Rogers did pass on the
Captain America title to Bucky Barnes
since this alternate Bucky wouldn't have
been the infamous Winter Soldier and
that could be why Steve now gets the
shield to Sam Wilson
because Bucky would have already gotten
the chance to be cap in another life and
in this timeline it would make more
sense for Sam to take on the shield
but caps alternate history with Peggy
wasn't the only new branch timeline
accidentally created by this movie the
original MCU cannon history still
happened but now so did a bunch of new
stuff so let's review what did caps
final mission fix and what did it leave
broken in a new timeline first time
stone power stone mind stone reality
stone all fixed it's pretty clear cap
replaced all those stones without
incident exactly where they had been
removed from the timeline restoring
history he gave the time stone back to
the ancient one he put the power stone
back in the orb in the Morag temple he
put the mine stone back in Loki's
scepter and returned that to the hands
of Hydra Sitwell or dr. lists now that
must have been hard for him to do but it
did erased caps hail Hydra moment and
prevented any possible partnership
between cap and Hydra and cap returned
the reality stone to Jane Foster in
Asgard now I know it's a bit weird
especially since the reality stone
changes its state from stone to angry
sludge but presumably he just dropped it
on Jane when she was sleeping and the
stone cosmically nude if they shift into
sludge and reabsorb back in a Jane's
body second mill near previously stolen
from 2013 Thor fist cap brought it with
him on his return journey and presumably
left it in Asgard with the reality stone
to prevent a branch timeline where Thor
would be left without Mjolnir against
the Dark Elves and Ultron third space
stone fixed cap returned a space stone
presumably somehow reconstructing the
tesseract cube and putting it back in
storage at lehigh in 1970 but Loki
stealing the space stone in 2012 new
timeline to be clear the branch point of
Loki taking the space stone and escaping
exists separate of the space stones
normal history in the main timeline
Loki stole previous history remains
unchanged battled New York captured in
prison on Asgard faked his death
disguised himself as Odin the events of
Ragnarok and then his real death by
Thanos all that stuff still happened but
now the Avengers Medellin created this
branch timeline in which an alternate
alive Loki continues
live Loki is both alive and dead like
the cat of the famous Schrodinger's cat
thought experiment which will henceforth
be known as Schrodinger's Loki next the
soulstone presumably fixed but the
soulstone is unlike the other stones and
that it requires a sacrifice right this
sacrifice cannot be undone but I think
we can assume that the stone can be
given back
I suppose it's also possible that cap
kept the soul stone and that break of
the timeline resulted in his new life
with Peggy a soul for a soul mate but
let's move on to these stolen Pym
particles from 1970 those are the ones
that cap took from Hank Pimm's lab so he
and Starr could get back to the present
day this one to me is a mystery I don't
know if cap could have replaced them
they only had so many of those Pym
particles they needed all the ones they
took to time-travel but at the end of
the movie Hank Pym was back so I guess
he could have created more Pym particles
to replace the ones that were taken but
remember Hank Pym and Howard Stark have
an established history of distrust we
saw that in the opening scene the first
ant-man Pym accused arc of stealing his
research you trim me into your errand
boy and I try to steal my research that
could have started from caps stealing
the Pym particles and Avengers in game
in 1970
so maybe cap never replaced those and
because they weren't Infinity stones it
just didn't cause a whole branch
timeline to break off but this brings us
to the most drastic change of the MCU
timeline
Thanos along with Gamora nebula the
black order all of Thanos forces in 2014
they all departed from the main timeline
jumping into the future to fight the
Avengers in the present day Gamora
switch sides and then her whereabouts
end up unknown but all the others ended
up dead 2014 nebula was shot by her
present-day self and the black order all
the other forces and banished himself
all dusted so that means starting in
2014 there is a new branch timeline a
separate alternate history without
Thanos and a timeline in which Peter
quill never met Gamora and perhaps the
guardians of galaxies never came
together but that also means that mid of
Lear and each tree would be left alone
the gauntlet would never exist
Xander would live on the Asgardian
refugees after Ragnarok would survive
and never get attacked
Loki Heimdall vision and every other
snap victim would live no post that five
year period would transpire and Steve
Rogers Tony Stark and Natasha Romanov
would all live on normally
these characters would still kind of
hate each other after the events of
Civil War but hey they'd still be
breathin so I want you to imagine that
normal timeline
and compare it to the post-apocalyptic
timeline in that five year gap after
thanasis snap many of you brought up
that the ancient one said that the
stones were necessary to maintain the
flow of space-time and if in the
beginning of endgame Thanos used the
stones to destroy the stones after he
snapped half of everything away wouldn't
that have plunged that main timeline
into chaos and disorder yeah and maybe
it did maybe
despite the Avengers bringing all six
stones into the future to bring back the
snap victims returning them back two
times in history before Thanos destroyed
them let this future in a more chaotic
dark place than we thought because that
timeline still includes Thanos getting
the stone snapping everyone away and
then destroying them it could be that in
that chaos a new dark force could rise
like a new MCU villain a cosmic entity
like Galactus or a nightmarish
interdimensional force like nightmare
rumored to be the villain of the next
Doctor Strange movie so if you have some
lingering doubts about the way Avengers
endgame left the MCU timeline
maybe those doubts could actually be the
questions that set up these
circumstances for future stories in
Marvel phase 4 my question for you is
which timeline would you prefer to be
the main MCU history going forward the
one we're currently with the post
endgame five years later future with
mostly everyone still alive - Tony Stark
Black Widow and caps an old man or that
other history I described the one
without Thanos in it and we're just kind
of left with the circumstances that we
had after Civil War so basically would
you prefer an MCU if Infinity Ward
endgame never happened because that
reality totally exists somewhere comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at ei vas and
subscribe to new rockstars on YouTube
and follow our new podcast feet inside
Marvel for early access to all of our
Marvel theories and breakdowns and soon
to come bonus audio exclusive episodes
thank you for joining me and if you
really want to make old man cap a
controversial figure just take a moment
to think about who he would have voted
for in 2016 Oh
any comments